what do you do when you have almost an
unlimited amount of money you buy and
stick a urine testing computer into the
urinals to measure players hydration
levels most NFL bathrooms have urine
charts to examine what your pee looks
like they go off color shades of course
but the Jag said enough of that we're
taking it up a notch and now a part of
their 120 million headquarters they have
this device so that when the guys go to
the bathroom a light goes off if it's
green you're good to go if it's yellow
it's telling you that you need to
hydrate more and if it's red you're
probably gonna have the people he's
chasing after you with a massive IB drop